hello everyone and welcome to round 8 of
the 2019 Tata Steel chess tournament
it's a game between Rocha champion
Magnus Carlsen and Richard report and
for Magnus Carlsen this is an excellent
opportunity to take his revenge as in
2017 edition of the Tata Steel chess
tournament richard reported defeated
Magnus Carlsen with the white pieces and
it is the only game that few of them
have ever played I believe in classical
time format I don't know about the
rapids and blitz but yeah so far Robert
has a positive score against Magnus
Carlsen and it is an excellent
opportunity for Carlson to take the lead
in the tata steel chess tournament and
also to exact his revenge now I don't
believe I was covering that tournament
in 2017 but I will put a link to that
game as it's such an amazing game Robert
really plays an all-out attacking game
really do check it out it will be the
first thing you see in the description
below but getting back to this game
yeah and it's definitely not the first
game we will cover from around 8 but
some of them are still being played and
we will talk about a bit more about the
standings after that so crossing opens
with E 4 we have C 5 the Sicilian
defence Knight to f3 we have e 6 the
French variation of the Sicilian the 4c
captures Knight captures and now Knight
to c6 we go into the tamaño variation
Knight to c3 and Queen to c7 the most a
very popular Bostic variation of the
Temenos g3 by Carlsen we have a 6 bishop
to g2 and now Knight to f6 and this has
all been played before at the standard
theory of the time on of we have castles
d6 and now Knight captures on c6 b
captures on c6 and now Knight to a4
Carlson did give up this tension that
was going on and he did strengthen black
central here as you can see black has
excellent control of the central squares
but Carson will now play c4 he will gain
excellent control of c5 and also the
night is very nicely controlling b6
ideas like Bishop to e3 followed by b6
come to mind
so rook to b8 taking hold of the newly
acquired semi-open B file and also
adding more protection to the b6 square
c4 as planned
sefa
and now comes b3 b3 is a new move in
this position obviously cousin came
prepared at the fight report nice in all
the games that were played in this
position there are but a few but
tonight's the c3 was the idea and cross
and finds a new way to play this
position obviously not before but b3 and
he decides to keep this night stranded
on the rim for her for some time and
okay we have Bishop to e7 Roberts
prepares the castle Bishop to b2 and now
comes castles as planned and here comes
Queen to e1 and now you have a lot of
ideas here f4 is an idea you definitely
want to push a 5 if black isn't careful
for example if he makes a slow move like
h6 then if I will be very strong Knight
has to retreat then f4 is coming and
white now has this excellent diagonal
and also white can open up the center
whenever he wants to end a free the
bishop on b2 so after Queen to e1 you do
have to react to this also you do have a
very strong dark square bishop well both
both of your bishops are strong ideas
like Queen the C 3 followed by some
threats of checkmate will be possible in
the future so a rapper doesn't allow if
I immediately was 97 further seize
control of d5 square and now rook to d1
we have rush up to b7 country in
Carson's very strong bishop on g2 and
now Queen the c3 as we've mentioned now
of course
a portable not blunt or something like
f5 and Queen captures with checkmate but
still here cousin is just testing you
know how rapid this feeling is here for
fight this year for what not and also
there's no danger in playing the move so
why not try it
McHale tall often said that you want to
give your opponent as many chances to
make a mistake as possible so Bishop to
f6 defending attacking the Queen of
course if the Queen moves then a trade
of bishops can occur Queen to d2 and
here upper just retreat Bishop e7 and he
says you're the world champion you have
the white pieces you know find the final
different move and cross and repeats the
Queen to c3 again threatens checkmate
and report repeats bishop to have six
and now Queen to d2 a report of course
does not mind drawing a game with the
black pieces against the world champion
so he repeats and here cousin if we if
cross and would repeat it then we would
have a draw by threefold repetition and
of course Qasim is not interested in
that we have f4 grabbing more space in
the center and now comes a five and a
very nice move taking a nice control of
the d4 square but also kind of locking
down this Bishop on b2 so his influence
is not felt at the moment but also it
weakens the d5 square so now cross and
can use the d5 square for his Knight
whenever he pleases we have Bishop to
see three now with ideas of going Bishop
to a5 and harassing the black queen a
report finds a very nice idea how to
deal with this he plays a burst of the
c6 and now if the queen is attacked he's
ready to create a queen bishop battery
to counter the the bishop on g2 and also
to attack d4 pawn and cousin does go for
it we have 25 Queen - b7 now with a
double attack against d4 pawn and now
finally knight retreats back into the
game but what has Crossan gained with it
yes the knight is now back in the game
and he does have a very nice bone
structure here in the center but he does
have a stranded Bishop on a5 but is it
is it really stranded or is it really
controlling the d8 squares so basically
khasinau gets to control the only open
file on the board so the bishop is very
useful on a5 we have he captures on f/4g
captures on a4 cross and doesn't mind
ruining his pawn structure in front of
the King a bit as he can always play
King to h1 and with a rook g1 maybe
double rooks on the G file and create a
strong attack against the rapid King
rook F to e 8 trying to increase
pressure against the center also Bishop
to f8 will be an idea in the future
improving the defense of the Kings side
'if I've by Carlsen now offering the
trade of the shops Bishop captures and
g2 Queen captures and g2 offering a
trade of Queens and here Robert decides
not to trade Queens but first he decides
to grab a cone in the center we have D
captures on e5 but now Karsten does not
recapture often plays Knight to d5 and
it
it's a very dangerous idea butter up the
c-7 will be quite a threat here first
efore is played
efore closing down the queen because
after a butter up to c7 that was
threatened you would have to move rook
and then the Queen would be undefended
their ideas like Knight captures which
check would open up an attack against
the black King so a lot of threats here
khasinau retreats with the Bishop Bishop
to c3 and here are already again Carson
is threatening this Queen captures on g7
checkmate and it is very hard to do to
defend against this Bishop to f8 is
possible but Robert was for f6 and there
doesn't seem to be anything wrong with
this as it seems to be the best defense
and here is a very interesting moment
because I caught a glimpse of what's s's
analysis was saying here as I was saying
that Rudy t1 is the way to go here we
want to make this rook lift but Carson
decides to not play the smooth crossing
first place came to h1 sorry after after
six King to h1 making room for the rook
on g1 and this interesting I could be
wrong but I I kind of thought that after
Carson played rook to h1 that says I
changed the devaluation and that saw
that King - h1 was actually better than
says his first move rook
looked D to e 1 I thought that was kind
of interesting but okay
I came to h8 the report also wants to
get rid of his King from the G file you
don't want this Knight captures on f6 to
be an option for white indefinitely rook
the g1 we have Bishop to f8 increasing
now the defense of the g7 pawn as again
cross him was threatening checkmate on
g7 and not night to e3 now cross and
Riemann averse the Knights to f5 where
it will pose great danger to the black
king queen to c6 report now monster as
quickly as possible bring the Queen over
to help out with the defense
rook the d5 cross and decides to go for
this very nice rook lift the rook is now
coming to h5 where a lot of nasty ideas
will become possible Queen to e6 we have
looked to h5 and now it's hard to say
which way to go rapper plate Queen to f7
which seems to be the best idea if roti
7 then
cousin has some very nice ideas with
queen g6 that's why Queen to f6 was
better as it controls here and now h6
will simply lose the 95 you lose the
rook here or if you if you move the rook
then Queen no longer controls g8 rook
captures on h6 check you remove the King
and get quick after a queen h7 checkmate
or you capture and then Queen g8 again
will be checkmate so after loop to h5
Queen to f7 was played by report and now
comes Queen to h3 threatening rook
characters on h7 not a lot of
possibilities here Robert decided to go
for g6 and cost and simply retreated
rook to h4 still leaving Blackwood a lot
of threats here and you do have to take
everything into consideration will white
push fi will white play Knight here and
go for some Knight captures an f6 ideas
well white go Knight to d5 so you
constantly have to keep aware of all the
threats and it's very hard for example
if you try to play something like the
King g8 to get away from the H file and
this very nasty diagonal then Luke
captures on g6 wins are also very
interesting if pawn captures then rook
checks and Queen checkmates on h6 or m
h7 and if you don't capture with the
pawn if you capture with the Queen then
Luke g4 wins the Queen and you do get
some material for the Queen but it's not
enough after overall as a queen captures
H captures now you get Queen g4 attacks
this also pressures the night rogue
defense Queen e6 check our rook f7 now
95 f6 is falling and black is just
falling apart
so after h4 o page 4 we have looked the
b6 trying to bring this rook also to
help out with the defense and here
Acosta has a few ways to continue this
he could go 95 immediately attack the
rook on d6 but there is always time for
this first he decides to go for f5 and
what do you do here well you could push
g5 but then the group will just capture
and you will not be able to recapture
due to this diagonal so here after this
upon to a5 report clean Knight to e5 and
what do you do here now Carson
introduces the knight into the central
95 attacks the rook
looked at these six and now finally not
recapture some afore that's a phone
grabbers move your you know don't be a
pawn grabber but rather f captures on g6
if you can force matters always do we
have a nightcap Tristan g6 the night for
me five is now defending in the g6
square and here Carlson has a few of
your options you could go Knight
captures give up your look temporarily
but then you get a Knight to d5 with
check this check is now so strong you
have to block at Bishop g7 but now loop
captures and now you have to give up the
Queen Queen captures Bishop captures on
g7 now you could capture let's say
either King captures then you get Queen
captures on h4 or you could try moving
but then again Queen captures and now
III you try to win this but it doesn't
work in Knight of 6 check simply wins
everything you force the King to capture
now and go into this fork Knight
captures and then again your king and
rook are forked it's all over after
Knight captures on g6 Carlsen decided to
go for a simpler way he played Bishop
captures on f6 what's check here rook
captures on f6 was played and it's a
very very interesting position because
if you play Knight captures and then
it's not all that easy to win this for
example Knight captures now you do have
root 2 G a check you win the Queen but
after Queen captures Knight captures
King captures and the Queen captures
from h4 you get III and it's actually
black who's very close to winning you
have to use extreme trickery to get out
of this Queen g5 check King h8 and now
Queen h5 attack the Rope that's
undefended and also guard e2 square
after the rook moves now you have to
block with the Queen and it's very
unlikely that you will be able to win
this with white so after this Bishop
captures on f6 rook captures Coulson did
not recapture but Carlson played a
different move
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the move constant played
that is the the only move that really
wins the game I'll give you a couple of
seconds as usual for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
you are you were the best and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
Bishop captures on h7 was played after
report so this
he resigned the game why did you resign
well if you don't capture then we we get
the exact same checkmate as we've
already seen the night to spendy he
cannot capture and after King moves now
either Queen age seven or eight six will
be checkmate on the other hand after
rook captures on h7 if you capture with
the Queen let's say link after some h7
then you get Queen capture skin captures
and now everything falls apart Knight
captures with check King has to move
nice capture sunny eight with check and
now king of $7.99 knight retreats and
the white is now up up the exchange it
with a much better position and it
doesn't matter that black has this
passed upon because blacks position is
just lost
for example 95 you get rook if one check
King to East seven now you get to this
check and it's very hard for black to
find a useful square for example here
Knight f6 check you lose this pawn and
now it's just a lost endgame I report
knows this and after look after some h7
Richard report resigned the game Austria
a very nice game by world champion mark
Olson from round eight of the 2019 Tata
Steel chess tournament I do hope you
enjoyed it as we will cover some other
games I believe Anand played a very nice
game against Parma dro so we're gonna
definitely check into that I would like
to thank Synod Arab a Ludwick mahalik
richard Fuhrman gurumarga Sri Lee and
Michael Pope for contribute to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos serie thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content thank you and I'll see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your
Sunday